a masked mob has attacked teachers and
students of an elite University in New
Delhi the incident is the latest in a
series of violent clashes across India
until Bora has sent us this update from
the jawaharlal nehru campus the
policemen are present here in numbers
today but on Sunday evening when some of
the students and teachers here were
under attack they took their time to
enter the university one must also get
clearance from the security guards so
the students who were beaten up are
asking well the security guards just
careless or was the administration of
the university complicit in the attack
that took place on Sunday evening about
50 people including women wearing masks
holding iron rods in their hands went
from one also to another they beat up
students as well as some teachers and
threatened the students as well at the
moment about 20 people students and some
teachers are receiving treatment at a
hospital in New Delhi now the students
who were beaten up allege that the group
that beat them up weren't gangsters but
part of the ABVP which is a student's
union affiliated with the hindu
nationalist party Janata Party the Home
Minister of the country who comes from
that party has ordered an inquiry and
several ministers in the current
government who've started in this
university have condemned the violence
but the students here don't feel safe
anymore many of them have left their
hostels and gone back home or to their
friends houses to stay there the big
question that people are now asking is
because there's a sense of disbelief and
panic then how could such an attack take
place our students now not safe inside
their hostels the students of this
university have been protesting against
the controversial citizenship law and
more recently also against the proposed
fee hike